[Laughter]
[Music]
this Paramecium is not having a
particularly good day you wouldn't be
either if the contents of your body were
being slowly consumed by a ciliate but
as you hopefully are watching this from
a comfortable position while not being
consumed we would understand if your
attention is diverted from the microbial
drama and instead focused on all the
shiny things like looking down on a city
at night from an airplane the moving
lights a sign of life at a distance
these shiny colors are actually crystals
visible this way under polarized light
so we have to use a special filter to
get these shots and they seem to be
connected to the paramecium's metabolism
we wanted to start with these crystals
because like we think they're stunning
and stunning is not necessarily the
first word that comes to mind when you
think of paramecia of the early
microorganisms discovered by scientists
paramecia have gone on to have perhaps
the most distinguished career studied by
scientists and students alike these
protozoans have been so useful as a
model organism that one scientist called
them the white rat of ciliates but while
paramecia have played an important role
in our understanding of genetics
microscopic movement and more importance
does not always imply excitement or
enthusiasm after all if we compare
paramecia to their perez o and brethren
what does a hairy oval have next to the
shifting shapes of the amoeba or the
strange movements of the you glenoid
that doesn't stop paramecia from wanting
some attention though there have been
plenty of times where we've set up a
recording of some beautiful organism
only to have paramecia come by and
photobomb our precious composition their
reliability in labs and frequent
appearance in classrooms might make
paramecia seem like a known quantity
the things we know we seem to have a
good grasp on we know that this is a
Paramecium a unicellular eukaryotes
covered in tiny hairs called cilia that
help it swim
we know that when scientists first began
describing paramecia they divided them
into two groups based on their
morphology Paramecium Oralia which have
a long tapered oval shape and Paramecium
were Saria which are shorter and rounder
we also know that they have multiple
nuclei one macro nucleus where
transcription happens and a number of
micro nuclei that vary across species
that become important during sexual
reproduction we've talked about
paramecia in a previous episode
describing the endosymbiotic algae that
reside inside of some species providing
sugar produced through photosynthesis in
exchange for the movement and shelter of
the surrounding cell so much of their
known nests rests on just how widespread
they are you can find paramecia in
freshwater brackish and marine
environments around the world though the
distribution of course varies by species
the ones that we've come to know best
seem to be the ones that are considered
cosmopolitan that's a word we use for
things that are found seemingly
everywhere recently scientists studying
Paramecium by aurélia collected from
ninety two spots around the world over
62 years of time found very little
genetic variation between the different
strains this kind of genetic similarity
indicates not only that these organisms
have traveled the world but that they
continue to keeping their populations
spread out and not diversifying into
different species but the ubiquity that
makes paramecia so known to us is itself
a question how did Paramecium manage to
find their way to all of these different
locations especially bodies of water
that are isolated from others unlike
some of the other aquatic organisms we
just on this channel Paramecium don't
form protective cysts that keep them
safe during a dry spell which makes it
that much harder for them to cross the
globe and its many dry spots through
experimentation and observation
scientists have confirmed the presence
of hitchhiking paramecia on the wet fur
of raccoons and on the bodies of snails
showing that they might be using the
surface of animals as moist taxis but
whether that explains the entirety of
their travels remains to be seen
paramecia are also subject to what you
might start to notice as a recurring
theme when it comes to the micro cosmos
while our early classification methods
relied on what we could see of an
organism's morphology the development of
various molecular techniques is
uncovering new patterns and
complications and how we define the
relationships between its species these
complications were hinted at by early
observations like the fact that the
broad morphologically defined label of P
or alia couldn't capture the strange
mating subdivisions that occurred in the
species groups of Peoria seemed
reproductively isolated from each other
in time as scientists gathered more
observations P or alia stopped referring
to one species of paramecia instead it
was redefined as a complex of 14
siblings named P prime or alia PTI
Aurelia P try irelia all the way up to P
kwatak Aurelia and a 15th subspecies
named P sana born I was discovered later
with more observation and genetic
techniques the pair Museum genus has
come to encompass 19 Morpho species
comprised of what are sometimes called
cryptic species these are species whose
morphological similarities Balai their
underlying differences when we look at
them in the microscope there is no way
for
to tell which species it is we would
mean to sequence their genome with words
like cosmopolitan and cryptic used as
technical terms to describe paramecia
they start to seem less like a textbook
organism and more like an international
microbe of mystery it might be fitting
them to learn from the experience of the
scientist Tracy M sana Bourne who began
working with protozoa in the 1930s sana
born developed many of the techniques
that turned paramecia into a model
organism his work so influential that it
has been memorialized in the name of
that 15th P or alias subspecies P sana
born I while researching paramecia sana
born became interested in the so-called
killer trait a subset of paramecia that
seemed able to produce toxins that
killed other paramecia these killer
paramecia all shared a trait the
presence of mysterious cytoplasmic
particles called Kappa sana born tracked
how these Kappa particles passed on
through generations proposing the plasma
gene theory to explain the patterns he
saw a hypothesis that these Kappa
particles were some special thing coded
in the paramecium's DNA but that could
self replicate on their own in the
cytoplasm and he was wrong it turned out
these Kappa particles aren't particles
they are bacteria another example of
endosymbiosis except that instead of
providing the nourishing promise of
photosynthesis
these bacteria turned their Paramecium
homes into killers
it took time for sauna born to accept
that his plasma gene theory didn't
explain Kappa particles but if paramecia
have come to model so much of what we
learn in science then looking more
broadly this microscopic organism also
models us and our own use of the
scientific process in a letter to
another researcher sana born reflected
on this on what it means to set aside
his own ego for the reality of the
microbe to know that studying nature
requires an understanding of our own
selves he wrote it was awful of me to be
so attached to a pet idea that was an
ordeal between my mind and my heart and
it took a while for the mind to win and
the heart to accept impersonal
scientific objectivity is a goal to be
sought by hard self discipline we are
not born with it
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us journey to the micro
cosmos is produced by complexly we
produce over a dozen different shows
including a new one ours Poetica it's a
co-production between complexly the
Poetry Foundation and the poet Paige
Lewis ours Poetica brings you a new poem
three times a week read by poets writers
artists and sometimes unexpected yet
familiar voices like like mine for
example you can check out a video of me
reading Edgar Allen Poe's the Raven we
think there are times for YouTube to be
high energy and times for it to be a
little bit more relaxing journey to the
micro cosmos an hour's Poetica are both
going for that second thing I also want
to say thank you for listening to my
extra gravelly voice today I have a cold
we haven't talked much about viruses on
this channel they are very difficult to
observe they're tiny
probably aren't really even alive but
they have colonized much of my upper
respiratory system right now and I'm
just pushing through also thank you so
much to everyone who has signed up to be
one of our patrons on patreon we are
extremely grateful to be able to make
this content and you are the reason why
we get to and if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
check out Jam and germs on Instagram
[Music]
you